all right check this out so i literally
recorded this in a studio
inside of my car
[Music]
what's up everyone it's chris here and i
don't know if you can tell but
sometimes i make videos and it's been
kind of tough because i've always lived
with a lot of roommates
housemates and lived in small apartments
with really thin walls in really noisy
neighborhoods
so trying to get crispy audio is just
annoying and especially when you're just
starting out
and you're gonna do like a thousand
takes it's really easy to get
self-conscious when you know that
everyone around you
can hear every single thing that you're
saying ideally you would just sound
proof and acoustically treat your whole
room
but if you rent that's kind of hard
because the second you touch your walls
your landlord is going to assassinate
you plus it's really expensive
so why don't you just go in your closet
now people give that tip a lot
and i don't believe anybody's actually
tried it
that's like a wikihow level tip this is
not gonna work and even if you have a
lot of clothes it's probably not
dense enough to soak up base frequencies
so we need a place that's quiet
private easy to access budget friendly
and has good acoustics
well i do drive this
a 2006 toyota corolla this is not the
sexiest car
ever it's not like 400 000 miles and i
literally can't sell it because even if
i repair it
it'll be worth less than the repairs
cost it has cloth seats which no one
likes more than leather but they're
actually way more sound absorbent the
floor is already built as a shock mount
against vibrations
so that should help and as you can see
there are no parallel surfaces inside
the car so we don't need to worry about
standing waves the big issue is going to
be the windows and the doors which do
have a lot of resonance
so for the treatment the best thing that
i tested was these moving mats
they're designed for dragging around
furniture but they're really dense
they're really flexible and they're
really cheap and then i got five of
these clamps that you can find at any
hardware store
i got the two inch sizes to make sure
that they fit on the handles above the
doors i'm gonna use the front right
handle the back right handle
the back left handle and there's none on
the left in the front so
i'm gonna use the visor i'm gonna push
the front seats forward so i can clamp
the two mats overhead
i'll clamp them together in the back and
because the mats are meant to prevent
punctures
i can actually remove one of the
headrests and use that to squeeze the
mat at the very top of the back window
now i'll fold the mats into the edges
and corners and then push the two front
seats back
and these will act as a reflection
filter on both sides of the mic if you
want to go really hard you could bring
in some
acoustic panels and just lean them
around the sides and then set up bass
traps on the floor but for most cases
it's not really necessary so we're gonna
test without it this is the recording
gear that i use at my desk
really just for yelling at teammates in
apex legends note the 15
desk arm this is important this is going
to let us stick the mic into the
recording booth but we do need a surface
to clamp it on
i forget what this thing is called but
we're gonna open it up and clamp the mic
onto the front wall
and here's what it looks like you see
the mic is between the two chairs and it
can be pulled back
into the booth hovering right at
recording level here's what it looks
like from the inside
and the mic is in a good spot so i'll
plug in the xlr cable
and then use that middle thing for cable
management the other end will go into
the audio interface
which will be connected to my laptop
which is also connected to the midi
keyboard on the dashboard
so now i guess we just hop into the
producer's chair and start cooking
something up
i found a copyright-free song i can just
cover but i can only use stock logic
plugins
so let's see what we can do
all right so we got a rough instrumental
so i'll hop into the back in the
recording booth where i'll track all the
vocals
and do the mixing mastering arrangement
and all that other stuff
and there we go um it turns out
acoustics won't fix your technique but
we got something
and if it's not studio quality i won't
be too mad because it is a car but let's
see how close we got
the dawn's early light
was so proudly we failed
at the twilight's last gleaming
whose bright stripes and bright stars
through the perilous spike
all the ramparts we've washed were so
gallantly
[Music]
you get the point obviously the sound
quality is not professional
but for most people it's definitely good
enough and you can just focus on getting
better at your craft
until it makes more sense to upgrade to
a studio setup it will be better if you
have a car with nicer sound deadening
but other than that for how
straightforward this is i think it
worked out pretty well so thank you for
watching i hope you found this helpful
drop a like comment subscribe and i'll
see you later
[Music]
you